bienvenue à tous pour ce nouveau numéro
de paris saclay tva numéro estival qui
vous emmène dans les potagers de danone
et search le leader mondial
adro alimentaire propose à ses employés
de cultiver leur potager voltaire
n'aurait pas qu'ils assument aussi notre
reportage sur les 48 heures techno
organisé par le crédit agricole c'était
la deuxième édition des robots de demain
aux nouveaux moyens de paiement du
secteur bancaire en passant par la santé
connecter toutes les dernières
innovations techno étaient présentes et
vous allez découvrir les innovations
aussi dans le domaine de l'aéronautique
un cluster phare de paris saclay des
grands groupes comme airbus safran
l'onera les startups les écoles
d'ingénieurs spécialisés innove dans ce
secteur crucial pour notre économie mais
aussi pour chacun d'entre nous nous
reviendrons sur terre avec la ligne 18
cette ligne de métro automatique polir à
orly à versailles elle desservira le
campus burban de paris s'appelait et au
vu des témoignages que nous avons
recueillis vous êtes impatients de la
voir cette ligne 18 notre agenda ce sera
à la fin de cette émission et oui déjà
des grands rendez vous pour la rentrée
on vous en dit plus à la fin d'émission
évidemment nous voici donc à palaiseau
le centre de recherches historiques de
danone
ici des équipes scientifiques
travaillent pour nous fournir des
produits laitiers désolé meilleur pour
notre santé mais le leader mondial
agroalimentaire a aussi son petit jardin
secret il est juste derrière moi même
entre search propose à ses employés de
bêcher de jardiner un projet lancé par
une salariée
erika perrier nous l'avons rencontré
l'alimentation c'est le coeur de la
mission de danone et donc parce que nous
voulons travailler en particulier sur
l'aspect de la reconnexion entre le
consommateur et l'alimentation
c'est important que dans notre centre de
recherche nous offrions cette même
possibilité pour nos salariés et donc
depuis quelques années on a lancé un
programme qui s'appelle caire et dont le
but est justement de tester différentes
options initiatives autour de la qualité
de vie au travail à l'intérieur de
keyria toute une partie qui s'appelle
bien dans mon assiette et dont le but
justement c'est travailler
spécifiquement sur l'alimentation est
donc une des dernières initiatives des
dernières expériences que l'on a lancé
ces jours ouvrira un potager
d'entreprise a donc ce potager
d'entreprise il est auto géré par un
certain nombre de salariés aujourd'hui
on en a une vingtaine à peu près qui
utilise de potagers et on essaye de
faire plus que simplement cultiver un
potager mais d'en faire aussi un lieu
d'expérimentation et donc à côté du
potager lui même mais on suit ceux qui
sont nos jardiniers l'entreprise pour
voir comment travailler sur ce potager
voilà sans occuper ça va aussi changer
leur rapport à l'alimentation le lien
social bref tout ce qui tourne autour de
l'alimentation et que là dans un centre
de recherche un endroit idéal pour pour
tester ses différentes expériences
potager car esso rep on a énormément de
besoins chez nous un premier temps sur
le plan nutritionnel en donnant accès à
nos salariés d'avoir une chance de
produire ce qu'eux mêmes ils vont
consommer et ça c'est tout enfin en lien
avec la mission du groupe danone c'est
une alimentation saine pour le plus
grand monde en plus le jardinage nous
permet l'amélioration de qualité de vie
en exerçant une activité en plein air et
de tisser des liens de communauté avec
des salariés provenant des services
différente aujourd'hui
le potager est composée de vingt
parcelles géré au niveau individuel ou
ambulants nous avons construit à une
communauté où on échange de bonnes
pratiques on s'entraide à arroser et on
partage même des graines de semence à
titre personnel s'occuper du potager me
donne 10 minutes de réflexion dans la
journée le temps de respirer et de faire
travailler mes mains j'ai rencontré de
nouveaux collègues durant cette aventure
et j'ai retrouvé un peu de campagne dans
ma vie très urbaine
aujourd'hui dans la première année du
potager on constate déjà que c'est un
succès mais on a vraiment hâte de voir
d'où ça peut aller l'année prochaine
est-ce que les robots vont nous aider à
faire notre jardin et bien pourquoi pas
les objets connectés envahissent notre
quotidien
pour la deuxième année consécutive les
48 heures techno nous ont permis de
découvrir les dernières innovations du
moment les robots personnels les
services de santé connecter les nouveaux
moyens de paiement et le futur de la
domotique
un événement organisé à saint quentin en
yvelines par le crédit agricole
paris saclay tv étaient sur place sur ce
site
nous sommes environ 3000 collaborateurs
plutôt versées dans les métiers de light
i et des moyens de paiement et des
opérations bancaires
pourquoi les 48 heures techno parce que
ici nous souhaitons faire en sorte que
les collecteurs souhaite exposer aux
nouvelles technologies au numérique et
plus globalement la digitalisation de
notre économie et de notre société au
bord de leur côté les présents dans nos
métiers bancaires vous êtes tous clients
d'une bon que vous ce rendez compte de
plus en plus ce sont
la banque par internet vous n'avez plus
dans votre agence et donc il faut que
nos co la terre puis suivent le
mouvement
un mouvement qui accélère aujourd'hui
par rapport aux années passées
donc cet événement c'est la rencontre de
environ huit fournisseurs stratégiques
partenaire stratégique groupes qui vont
de microsoft à accenture ibm oracle mais
également des start up puisque le monde
aujourd'hui c'est des start up des
start-ups et toi c'est la rapidité c'est
le service c'est la simplicité
donc on fait cet événement pour ça en
plus des start up qui sont forcément
aussi implanté sur le territoire
parce que nous souhaitons développer
l'économie territoriale
nous avons une chance extraordinaire
d'avoir à côté de nous des fleurons de
l'industrie française comme airbus
safran thales est également un élément
qui rond dans notre dynamique on a créé
notre programme de transformation c'est
le cluster paris saclay peu
d'entreprises ont cette chance d'avoir à
côté de chez eux
on va dire demain huitième pôle
scientifique mondiale et 25% de la
recherche
notre objectif en faisant ça c'est de
montrer qu'une entreprise comme une
banque où on pense que la bombe ce n'est
que des conseillers clients non la
banque c'est celle de plus en plus le
digital de plus en plus le numérique est
donc en faisant cet événement s'est
aussi montrée sur le territoire et
notamment aux jeunes que les métiers de
la bombe sont des métiers d'avenir
l'innovation elle est au coeur du
cluster aéronautique de paris saclay
alors oui nous sommes d'accord toulouse
reste la capitale de l'industrie
aéronautique française mais votre
territoire peut prétendre au statut de
technopol dans ce secteur donc en gros
comme airbus safran ou des centres de
recherche comme l'onera sont implantées
ici sans compter les nombreuses start-up
ou les écoles d'ingénieurs spécialisés
voilà qui crée une dynamique indéniable
regardez le néracais le centre français
de recherche aérospatiale donc c'est un
établissement public qui est vraiment
dédié à la recherche dans le domaine de
l'aéronautique du spatial et de la
défense et qui rassemble un ensemble de
compétences et de moyens expérimentaux
assez unique en france vraiment orientée
vers la satisfaction des besoins
notamment de notre industrie nous sommes
un établissement qui est le résultat
d'une vraie volonté politique de l'état
de se doter d'un instrument pour
justement ses activités de recherche de
défense et nous nous sommes d'ailleurs à
ce titre placé sous la tutelle unique du
ministre de la défense
nous sommes un des premiers occupants de
ce plateau puisque nous sommes implantés
ici depuis 1952
quelques exemples de réalisations et de
travaux très très récent bien tout ce
qu'on fait dans le domaine de la de la
propulsion des avions pour le futur avec
des coopérations notamment avec le
motoriste safran qui vient d'installer
un centre de recherche qui s'appelle
safran tech sur le plateau est par
ailleurs nous avons une grosse activité
autour du futur de la défense et nous
sommes présents je dirais dans dans
toutes les grandes fonctions
stratégiques qui ont été identifiés dans
les livres blancs successifs de la
défense
nous préparons clairement le long et le
très long terme pour l'onera et je
dirais pour tous les
les partenaires qui sont présents sur ce
plateau qu'il s'agisse de centres de
recherche comme nous d'universités
d'écoles de grandes écoles en
particulier est naturellement de
l'industrie le plateau de saclay saclay
et palaiseau c'est vraiment une aventure
qui ne fait que commencer et beaucoup
d'industriels vont rejoint
progressivement le plateau pour vraiment
créer j'irai des modes de coopération et
de partenariat nouveau où on va faire de
l'innovation où on va pas simplement
j'irai faire de l'art la recherche et de
la technologie mais où on va chercher à
convertir beaucoup plus rapidement des
avancées de la recherche en produits
ayant géré une valeur économique et
ayant des conséquences très directe par
exemple sur l'emploi qui est un sujet
qui concerne véritablement tout le monde
l'association des entreprises delta 230
en yvelines soutient le projet de
cluster aéronautique
c'est un projet de développement
économique important pour le territoire
nous allons les grandes entreprises qui
contribuent à ce projet comme airbus
avec des sujets très innovant qui vont
permettre d'associer à la fois la
technologie issue d'un grand groupe
et puis les apports sur de l'innovation
issus de pme du territoire qui vont
pouvoir contribuer tessa sur un projet
qui se développera sur l'aéroport de
toussus-le-noble autour de l'avion
électrique ifan le projet de cluster
aéronautique s'intègre dans les projets
de paris-saclay donc nous sommes au
coeur du territoire de l'eau yen va
faire partie des projets industriels qui
mêle à la fois développement économique
mais également des aspects recherche
innovation et qui pourront toucher
également des établissements
d'enseignement et de recherche du
territoire comme l'estaca il ya
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
on redescend sur terre avec la ligne 18
cette ligne de métro automatique
permettra de relier l'aéroport d'orly à
la gare de versailles 35 km de lignes
neuf gares elle desservira évidemment le
campus urbain de paris saclay c'est
aussi un vaste chantier
qu'en pensez vous eh bien nous sommes
allez vous poser la question d'aller de
versailles à massy c'est compliqué je
suis passé par paris ce matin pour
détendre
londres est en train métro un rer et là
je reprends un rer en temps à revers et
enfin oui c'est compliqué donc s'il y
avait une ligne directe c'est sûr que ça
arrangera les choses
oui un peu plus de transport ça serait
bien parce que rien de monter sur paris
nous faut une heure est allé jusqu'à
orly vers ces chantiers relie
directement ça peut être très pratique
nous évite de prendre la voiture est
payé je travaille à massy en fait mais
il m'arrive d'aller sur paris avec le
rer b qui m'arrive à la mort ni c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est assez long
d'aller à orly avec les moyens de
transports actuels c'est vrai même avec
l'orlyval
je crois que ça vient entre 30 et 40
minutes donc j'ai cru comprendre que ça
mettrait moins de dix minutes donc c'est
quand même intéressant
quand on va aller sur le plateau alors c
ces pratiques là pour aller à
l'université paris-sud des fois c'est
aussi rapide à pieds 7 pouces pour les
échanges avec les autres comme tout ce
qui ya son coin que ça pourra coller une
île je pense que ça va un peu
décongestionner la ligne b sincèrement
c'est des fois y'a pas de train et des
fois faut attendre environ 35 me soit
arrivée à paris après faire des
changements adhère donc un trait en
ligne jacques je pense que c'est une
très très bonne idée
comme mon avis ça peut être un bon
projet dans la mesure où il va y avoir
quand même certaines atteint comme
interconnexion entre versailles saint
quentin saclay qui sont des pôles quand
même assez important au niveau au niveau
emploi
donc ça peut avantager pour couler les
passagers qui pour se déplacer sur ces
lignes j'ai entendu parler de la ligne
18 h tous accès franchement ça peut être
utile pour ceux qui n'ont pas l'habitude
d'aller autre part qu paris en fait j'ai
travaillé sur saclay j'étais obligé de
prendre ma voiture ou bien mon scooter
pour y aller parce que pour yann
transport sans grosse galère ça soit en
bus ou en train
c'est pas de facilités pour y aller donc
je te veux juste prendre ma voiture
personnelle y aller alors que j'avais la
carte manigod qui étaient offerts par
l'entreprise et j'étais obligé de m'en
passer
quand la voiture donc la ligne serait
bien
voilà pour ce tour d'horizon de
l'actualité de votre territoire pour
beaucoup les vacances approchent mais
avant de partir n'oubliez pas votre
agenda pour inscrire ses rendez vous de
la rentrée il ya déjà les entretiens
enseignants entreprises c'est la dixième
édition
ils se tiendront les mardi 25 et
mercredi 26 août sur le campus de
l'école polytechnique
tout le programme de cette université
d'été et sur le site e 2015 point fr à
noter aussi cette conférence sur le
patrimoine architectural le vôtre celui
qui est en train de se construire
actuellement titre provisoire de cet
événement campus urbain paris saclay
construire le patrimoine architectural
du 21e siècle
les architectes présenteront les projets
en cours sur le campus ce sera le
dimanche 19 septembre de 16 heures à 17
heures au plateau des projets amorcés
voilà pour la rentrée d'ici là profitez
de l'été mais nous on revient très vite
on revient le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro de paris saclay télé
d'ici là vous pouvez vous tenir informés
grâce à notre site eps.fr merci de votre
attention à 13
m